you have studied and criticized powerful
leaders and nations
in times of global conflict and
struggles for power
so let me ask you
what do you think motivates vladimir
putin
is it power legacy fame geopolitical
influence or the flourishing of a nation
he loves
and represents
i have no
particular insight into
putin's mind i can only
watch the actions over the last
20 25 years
and read the statements
took power
about
almost 25 years ago has
held it since
prime minister president
uh
his first task
was to try to
overcome the
chaos and disarray
of the 1990s
during the 90s
gorbachev
had a proposal
uh called for
a cooperative
enterprise with the west
they would share an effort to rebuild
what he called a
common european home
uh in which there would be no military
alliances
just
russia
western u.s accommodation
with a move towards social democracy in
uh former ussr
and uh
comparable moves in the united states
well that was quickly smashed uh the
united states had no interest in that uh
clinton came along pretty soon early 90s
russia was
induced to
adopt
what was called shock therapy
harsh
quick
market transformation
which devastated the economy
uh created enormous social or disarray
uh
rise of
what are called oligarchs kleptocrats
high mortality
and clinton started the policy of
expanding
nato to the east
in violation of
firm unambiguous promises
to gorbachev not to do so
uh yeltsin
[Music]
putin's friend opposed it
other russian leaders opposed it but
they didn't react
they
accepted it
when putin came in he continued that
policy
meanwhile didn't
reconstruct the russian economy russian
society became a viable deeply
authoritarian society
under his
tight control
he himself was
organized a major
kleptocracy with him in the middle he
apparently became very wealthy
on the international front he pretty
much continued the former policies
as
u.s
diplomats practically every diplomat who
had any
contact with russia
had been dispatched there or knew about
it
as they all warned from the 90s that
what clinton was doing expanded by his
afterwards
was reckless and provocative
that
russia did have a
clear red line before putin which he
adhered to
namely no nato membership for
ukraine and georgia
this is pretty much how things
went on
through the
2000s
uh 2014
2008
george bush president bush did invite
ukraine to join nato that was vetoed by
france and germany
but under u.s pressure it was kept on
the agenda
the russians continued to object western
diplomats
including the
present current
head of the cia and his predecessors
warned that this was
reckless provocative shouldn't be done
continued
uh
putin didn't do much he stayed with it
until pretty recently
after 2014
the uprising that uh
throughout the
former president who was pro-russian
uh instituted anti-russian laws
uh
the united states and nato began to
a policy of
moving to effectively
integrate ukraine
into the nato command
joint military exercises uh
training uh
sending weapons and so on
uh
putin
objected other russian leaders objected
their unit unified on this but
didn't do much
continued with the
proposals that uh
nato that ukraine be
excluded from nato
and that there be some form of
autonomy for the
dunbas region
meanwhile in reaction to the
uprising the might on uprising 2014
russia moved in and took over crimea
protecting its uh one
warm water base and a major naval base
u.s objected and recognized it but
things continued without
notable conflict
won't go through all the details when
joe biden came in he
expanded the
program of
what
u.s military journals called de facto
integration of
ukraine within nato
uh
developed proposed
september
2021 proposed
enhanced program of preparation for
the
nato admission
extended with a
formal statement in november
we're now practically up to the invasion
putin's position hardened
france
mainly france to an extent germany
did make some
moves towards
possible negotiations
putin
dismissed them uh
moved on to the
direct invasion
uh
that's
what what are his to get back to your
question what motivates him
i presume what he's been saying all
along
uh
namely
establishing his legacy as a
leader who
overcame the
extensive destruction of russia and
massive weakening over it restored its
position as a world power
prevented ukraine from entering nato
it may have
further ambitions as to
dominating and controlling ukraine very
likely
there is a
theory in the west that he suddenly
became a
total madman who wants to
restore the great russian empire
this
is combined with uh
gloating over the fact that the russian
military is a
paper tiger that
can't even conquer
cities a
couple of kilometers from the border but
defended not even by a regular army
but somehow along with this
he's planning to
attack nato powers conquer europe
who knows what
it's impossible to put all these
concepts together they're totally
internally contradictory
so
what's my judgment
i think what motivates him is
what has been demonstrated in his
actions
restore
russia as a great power
restore its economy
uh controlling
as a
total dictatorship
enriched himself and his cronies
uh establish a legacy as a
major figure in russian history
make sure that ukraine does not join
nato
and
probably by now is pardoned to position
maintain
crimea
and the southeastern corridor to russia
and uh
some ambiguous agreements about the
dunbas region
that looks like his motivation
there's much speculation that goes
beyond this but
it's very hard to reconcile with the
uh
the assessment of the real world by the
same people who are making the
uh
grandiose uh speculations
putin has been in power for 22 years do
you think power has corrupted him
i don't think anything's changed
it seems to me it's about his policies
are about the same as what they were
they've
changed in response to changed
circumstances
so very recently right before the
invasion
a few weeks before for the first time
putin
announced
recognition of the independence of the
unbest region
that's a stronger position than before
much stronger up till then he had pretty
much kept to the
long-standing position of uh
some kind of accommodation within a
federal structure in which the
dunbest region would have considerable
autonomy
so that's a portioning of the position
so even the human mind
of vladimir putin the man
i can't read his mind i can only see the
policies that he's pursued and the
statements that he's made
there are many people speculating about
his mind
and as i say these
speculations are
first of all not based on anything
never said anything about trying to
conquer nato and but more importantly
they are totally inconsistent
with the analyses of russian power
by the same people who are making the
speculations
so we see
the same individual
speculating about
uh putin's
grandiose plans to
become peter the greats and
conquer
start attacking the nato powers
on the one hand saying that
on the other hand gloating over the fact
that his military powers
so miniscule he can't even
conquer
the
towns a couple miles from the border
well it's impossible to make sense of
that position
why did russia invade ukraine on
february 24th
who do you think is to blame
who do you place the blame on
well who's to blame
any power that commits aggression is to
blame
so i continue to say as
i have been for many months
that the invasion
putin's invasion of ukraine
is on a par with
such
acts of aggression as
the u.s invasion of iraq
uh this the stalin
hitler invasion of poland
other acts of
uh
supreme international crime under under
international law aggression of course
he's to blame
you